So many things go wrong when you're starting a company,...
...and often, I think people ask what mistakes should you avoid making.
And my answer to that question is don't even bother trying to avoid mistakes...
...because you're gonna make tons of mistakes, right?
And the important thing is actually learning quickly from whatever mistakes you make...
...and not giving up.
There are things every single year of Facebook's existence that could have killed us,...
...or made it so that it just seemed like moving forward...
...and making a lot of progress it just seemed intractable,...
...but you just bounce back and you learn.
And nothing is impossible.
You just have to keep running through the walls.